l'exode pour survivre cette femme de 66
ans s'est rendue aux archives de la
Croix-Rouge avec un objectif
rechercher les informations sur des
parents juifs qui auraient immigrant en
Israël pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale en Israël la loi du retour
offre à toute personne ayant un grand
parent juif la possibilité d'immigrer
dans le pays et de devenir citoyen
israélien dès son arrivée
je sais que ma mère et ma grand-mère ont
été évacuées de Moscou si mon fils
décide de partir je le suivrai s'il
décide d'émigrer je le ferai aussi et
regarde
il y a quelques semaines le président
russe appelait une mobilisation
partielle causant une fuite massive de
citoyens russes vers des pays d'accueil
Israël est l'un d'entre eux pour
certains à 48 ans cette entrepreneur se
voit forcer de devenir un réfugié russe
comme ses grands-parents il y a des
années avec ses précieux sésame ce sont
ses actes de naissance et de mariage qui
ont pu faciliter les îles de son fils de
17 ans
le 24 février a brisé la vie de mon fils
il avait de très bonnes perspectives ici
deux médailles d'or des victoires aux
Olympiades russes de programmation et
une voix ouverte vers n'importe quel
université ce n'est ni un amoureux de
l'idéologie du pouvoir ni un militariste
il n'a donc aucun doute sur son départ
[Musique]
le mois dernier le gouvernement
israélien a prouvé à l'unanimité le
programme d'absorption des immigrants de
Russie dans mon temps de 90 millions de
séquelles soient près de 26 Millions
d'euros la possibilité d'étendre la loi
de retour aux immigrés de Russie à la
quatrième génération mm envisagée